how you feel about uh
being back on
on the station i mean it's cool you know
i launched the show and then they picked
it up as an affiliate so it's dope to be
able to be like hey well like
i
am on the station but i don't work for
them
so i'm on every night
but i don't work for it for them
so the good parts about being on the
station are there
some of the cool relationships i still
have i mean i i never lost any
relationships at the station it's just
now i kind of the [ __ ] that i don't like
to do or that i wouldn't like about
dealing with you know having like
all staff meetings and blogging and [ __ ]
and like stuff i don't want to do i
don't have to do any of it yeah i just
do me so you kind of just got your own
lane
you could just rock i literally yeah i'm
on the shows all over the country so i
do one show every day and it runs in a
bunch of markets all over the country so
did you have that same leverage uh your
last lap at the uh station
no because when i the last time i worked
at the station
you know i moved from
i was in tampa and then i went tampa to
l.a and
a little pit stop in phoenix
um nah nah of course not no i mean you
know they gave me a great opportunity
and coming to l.a changed my life you
know what i'm saying so yeah but like i
was already thinking like when i was in
the pandemic
and i was able to like not have to go to
the radio station every day
and we were voicing our show from home
because
everything was shut down yeah
it gave me so much flexibility to like
get so much other money
yeah and and con congrats on uh on the
on the situation man yeah so you know
it's just
it was already something i wanted to do
so it worked out man and doc winter
shout out to doc docks with real one
ao is a real one you know they they
didn't let me go because they wanted to
clearly they brought me back so you know
uh shout out to them and what was good
with the with the with the artists
you're working with man oh yeah yeah you
know we got a little label that we have
ready set label i mean it's little right
now
now but we just put a record out that's
doing well with um
t-pain uh featuring it's a lexus
featuring t-pain so yeah man we working
you wanna you wanna know some funny [ __ ]
i'ma just let y'all know how good i am
right
you see how i just went into journalist
j-mode real quick i just like i just
started interviewing him he doesn't even
realize that this whole interview i've
been interviewing him just could this
could this be because you have some
journalists stuff coming down the
pipeline oh man i just
i've been in some media training since
june and people have been telling me how
to work this little media thing so why'd
you get media training because of our
interview definitely
they're like yo